[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en novembre 2000 23 je vais sans doute
réalisé l'un des rêves les plus fous de
nous
atteindre le pôle sud depuis écoute
devant partie une expédition de plus de
650 kilomètres sur une quarantaine de
jours sur ce continent si mystérieux
père en parti
vivre une expérience intemporel où le
soleil ne se couche sera jamais un monde
sans bruit ou la seule odeur vous pourra
s'en tirer sans doute la mienne
passé par toutes les émotions et pleure
le bonheur la douleur
vivre une aventure entière
à ce moment là dans la salle il ya deux
types de personnes le premier quart
d'entre vous aient déjà avec moi un
parti qui imaginent ce froid cette
tension cette expédition
et trois autres quartiers de se demander
pourquoi tu veux faire ça
eh bien j'ai pas d'explication
rationnelle à vous devez c'est une
accumulation de plein de choses c'est
tout mon parcours de vie ça commence par
l'éducation que mes parents m'ont
apporté cette curiosité qu'ils ont su
cultiver au mans ça passe par des
expériences passées avec des amis avec
de la famille pourquoi pas mon passif
militaire je pourrais même vous dire que
le blanc est ma couleur préférée
et c'est un peu tout ça à l'offre c'est
pas parce que vous avez tel parcours
vous aurez tel rêve un moment il faut
savoir lâcher prise il se laissait
et c'est pour ça que je sais
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant depuis trois
ans c'est ce rêve d'antarctique qui
m'animait et qui me fera et jusqu'où
vous allez me dire c'est bien encore un
rêveur qui est de présenter un projet
impossible demong redescend sur terre
mon gars le pôle suite rappelé quinze
mille kilomètres les températures
avoisinant les moins 40 degrés et pas
mike horn a surtout pas son physique
[Musique]
si vous rigolez et là c'est pas très
sympa moi
et vous allez sans doute un peu raison
si on veut aller plus loin dans un rêve
il faut le transformer en objectif et ça
ça passe par prendre du recul c'est
revoir devant par connaître nos besoins
donc en train d'en limite en réalité se
passe par se connaître soi et c'est pour
ça que j'ai décidé de partir de partir à
l'aventuré d'aller au mont blanc qui
engage à rouen la folie de vivre toutes
ces expériences pour mieux connaître
j'y cherchais une certaine force
personnelle qui cherchait sans doute un
peu me limite et j'ai trouvé tout autre
chose qui est trop réduit sens qu'il
roulait du partage en à peine quelques
jours j'arrivais à gré des biens très
fort très intime avec des inconnus de la
veille
et c'est au sommet du kilimandjaro tout
en haut et l'afrique que j'ai compris
réellement ce qui était une aventure une
aventure ce n'est pas atteindre le
sommet du contact et c'est vivre son
ascension ensemble
dans la vie si on veut atteindre quelque
chose il ya deux manières soit on
s'entraîne seul on apprend par soi même
et on prend tous suivi avant le silence
ou alors on intègre un groupe on apprend
on transmet on partage on s'entraide et
surtout on avance ensemble
si je voulais monter pour être te ment
ce projet d'antarctique j'allais avoir
besoin d'une équipe non pas pour partir
avec moi sur le terrain ce que j'aurais
jamais trouvé personne mais et personne
solide sur qui je pourrais monter ce
projet et le construire les fondations
et gens bienveillants sortie je sors m
et volée et surtout avec un vrai regard
critique sur mes choix
naturellement on va se tourner vers nos
amis notre famille on sait si les
convaincre il suit les premières boucles
les premières critiques
mais petit à petit on va réussir à
fédérer autour de nous et quand ce
projet il sourit qui sera suffisamment
dur suffisamment solides pour vous
suffisamment mûr il faudra passer l'état
pratique
présenter ce projet avant par an
bon voilà apparemment ça fait déjà
quelques temps maintenant que je
travaille avec des amis souvent projets
d'expéditions a commencé à contacter du
monde on a commencé à structurer notre
travail donc voilà je me lance
je veux partir en antarctique en
solitaire à skis pour atteindre le pôle
sud
pour qu'ils imaginent et bien pendant un
petit moment j'ai installé en froid à la
mise au point et je vais pas les blâmer
il en fallait sans doute un peu de temps
et nous sommes d'abord empêché de
continuer à cultiver ce qu'elle a
travaillé autour de ce projet est un
jour ne sont revenus voir ils montrent
une phrase que j'oublierai sans doute
jamais une phrase qui va toucher au plus
profond des
pierres ne pourront pas dire que nous
n'avons pas peur et si c'est réellement
sainte pour m
alors nous ferons tout pour nuire
et c'est comme ça que ma famille a
commencé à travailler avec moi sur ce
projet et parents ma soeur on a mis
toute cette équipe que j'avais imaginé
au sommet du kilimandjaro était ici
enfin à dégoter donc on a continué à
cultiver serait demandé des coups de
main à droite à gauche et et éthicienne
graphisme avis bénévoles c'était juste
génial au fond c'est tous ensemble en
direction du pôle sud
et au bout d'un moment je sais pas
poser des questions sans doute un peu
1,52 à poster mais je suis demandé
pourquoi les gens s'investissent autant
dans un projet qui à première vue mais
leurs
biens sur la déjà tous dépanner
quelqu'un on a rendu service
déménagement donner du lait un voisin et
là je sais pas si vous voyez quelque
chose de bien plus fort
et si finalement ce rêve il n'était pas
aussi un peu le leur et si avec notre
travail chacun avait su s'approprier
partie serait surtout saisir cette
opportunité
quelque temps je suis allé voir coralie
va quitter nice hier du projet faisait
un retour d'expérience suite à une
expédition avait mené en la money sur
des essais ya encore un travail toujours
aussi qualitatif de sa part
investissement hyper important et donc à
la fin de cette réunion lundi quand ali
voilà ça veut dire beaucoup de temps tu
travailles avec nous donc moi aussi a
même fortement merci pour ton travail et
donc si tu me le permet je voudrais être
rémunéré
elle me regarde un peu offusqué
jeu prendra pas bien je fais pas partie
critique et bien sûr que si tu fais
partie de l'équipe en est avec ton
travail tout travail mérite salaire et
ça ne paraîtrait normal de se mobiliser
pour ça
et dampierre t'as pas compris c'est pas
ça qui m'intéresse moi ce que je veux
c'est faire partie fixe
pour vous imaginez bien sorti de ce
rendez vous un peu peur et en arrivant
chez moi je me suis rendu compte qu'on
avait réussi à greek chose de très fort
quelque chose de bien plus grand que ce
projet d'antarctique
courally elle ne cherchait pas du tout
l'argent c'était pas ça son moteur est
ce qu'elle voulait faire si vivre cette
aventure atypique et même pourquoi pas
apprendre des choses utiles dans son
équipe c'est dans cette même logique car
mendient la graphie du projet puis sa
vraie première expérience
professionnelle à l'écrit ou alors le
chu de rennes qui supervise toute ma
préparation physique me donne des
sciences ne laisse pas ce que je
n'arrive même pas à finir tout ça pour
que je sois prêt le jour du départ et
surtout je leur amène un maximum de deux
députés
c'est dans cette même logique on veut
ouvrir le projet au plus grand nombre
aux entreprises aux écoles primaires aux
écoles supérieures aux associations on
veut permettre à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent de vivre qu'au bout de cette
aventure et surtout d'en retirer quelque
chose
si on veut imaginer ce qui pour moi un
projet surtout la force d'un projet peut
facilement prendre l'exemple d'un drap
nos un radeau vous allez commencer à
construire seul avec des objets trouvés
à droite et gauche et le jour vous
considérez que ce projet sera dos il
sera insuffisant solide vous commencerez
à prendre la mer en direction d'autres
rêves en direction de l'horizon bien sûr
votre ado il est encore trop fragile
pour atteindre à l'horizon alors vous
allez devoir vous arrêter sur le schéma
assez différentes haltes vous allez
rencontrer des gens avec des compétences
avec des matériaux qui vous permettront
de renforcer ce radeau et pourquoi pas
même de le transformer en un réel bateau
et tous ces gens qui vous ont ils vu
aussi ils veulent atteindre l'horizon
leur horizon est pas forcément le même
que les autres
et finalement pourquoi faire un pourquoi
pas faire bout de chemin ensemble
l'an certaines personnes monteront dans
votre ado dans votre bateau je l'espère
certaines personnes lisandro est ce qu
ils réellement importantes et longues et
les gens là où ils le veulent
parce que le jour où vous vous attendrez
votre horizon vous verrez tous ces gens
autour de nous au prennent leurs rêves
c'est ça qui est réellement important et
c'est là où sera la beauté de votre
bruit parce que le meilleur moyen de
réaliser un rêve c'est déjà de le
partager et surtout de permettre aux
autres d'atteindre les lèvres merci
[Applaudissements]